listen it was made in 1942 uh-huh and
it's kind of the premier bluegrass
guitar is called a herringbone this
thing this trim that goes around here is
a herringbone trim the pre-war Martens
everybody's lusting after and even in
1975 this guitar was $2,500 which was
insane 120 bucks brand-new and so I saw
this guy at a festival he had it in the
case and I have a sign on it
pre-war d-28 $2,500 and I said can I see
that guitar and he's a kid can you
afford it and I said no sir I'd sure
like to see it you know so he opened up
the case and it was this guitar and and
I had a newer Martin from like 1971 I
said would you consider a trade he was a
crafty old dude and so I gave him like
1,600 bucks in my guitar and that's 69
bucks that I bought this guitar with was
all the money I had in the world
it was everything it was every dime and
I was broke dead broke had no money in
my account but I had a gig for a couple
of hundred bucks a week and I figured
I'll be all right start this addiction
yeah pretty much
any time I had some extra money I was
buying a guitar yeah
[Music]
feels like a piano
[Music]
so if place burns down I'm gonna
probably grab this one first